unsere reporter sind in deutschlands
wintersport gebieten unterwegs als
erstes schauen wir nach winterberg ins
sauerland dort ist mein kollege
sebastian prengel und bei ihm ist
vinterbergs bürgermeister michael
beckmann ihr sebastian wie sieht die
situation dort heute aus hat sich die
lage denn etwas entspannt naja
winterberg ist komplett abgeriegelt die
polizei hat heute morgen sämtliche in
den ort hinein abgeriegelt es gibt
außerdem ein betretungsverbot für eine
skipiste das auch durchgesetzt worden
die polizei war mit einer hundertschaft
vor ort die haben die leute aufgefordert
nach hause zu gehen das sind natürlich
harte maßnahmen für einen ort der vom
tourismus lebt und bei mir ist jetzt
michael beckmann der bürgermeister von
winterberg herr beckmann können sie uns
einmal erklären warum mussten sie zu
drastischen schritten greifen
ja wir haben die ganze woche schon
verschiedenste maßnahmen umgesetzt
und jetzt war gestern neben der schritt
notwendig geworden internet auch
tatsächlich abzuriegeln weil wir der
situation nicht mehr her geboten
das heißt es sind einfach zu viele leute
am freien wochenende nach winterberg
reingekommen der woche schon an und die
sache super sprung ist nicht mehr ab und
gestern irgendwann war es dann soweit
dass man die lage nicht mehr beherrscht
hat und wir haben gestern schon die
ersten straßen gesperrt und dort wurde
das sehr konsequent durchgesetzt wir
haben ein rettungsboot auf den pisten
ausgesprochen
das wurde durchgesetzt damit wir
überhaupt wieder zumindest in der
kernstadt unserer stadt duisburg
wie reagieren denn die leute auf diese
maßnahmen haben sie verständnis ja
einige am verständnis viele leider nicht
und das kann ich überhaupt nicht mehr
verstehen wir sind in einer an der mit
einem lock down
der ministerpräsident habe ich lasse
dazu braucht ein zuhause zu bleiben aber
das hat alles nichts gebucht
also ist die zeit der appelle jetzt
vorbei die war stößt in ihnen aus wenn
die leute darauf mit unverständnis
reagieren und den menschen tief
enttäuscht wir sind zu uns gekommen
haben ihren müll auch in teilen
hinterlassen weil wir sind eben nur wie
viele andere städte und gemeinden
nordrhein westfalen auch und deswegen
bin ich
gehört harte maßnahmen in winterberg und
damit gehen wir zurück nach berlin
vielen herzlichen dank nach winterberg
straßensperrungen und verkehrschaos sie
gab es auch im harz und dort wollen wir
jetzt den stehen hinschauen mein kollege
denis lochte ist dort vor ort im
westharz dennis wie sieht es denn dort
heute aus ja die tourismusbehörde hat
hier im harz ein appell an die menschen
gerichtet und gesagt bitte denkt
wirklich drüber nach müsst ihr momentan
den harz besuchen
man muss sagen diese appelle ist
verpufft die sind die leute sind zu
tausenden heute wieder in den harz
gekommen
schon seit dem frühen morgen hat das
hier verkehrsbehinderungen gegeben
die parkplätze beispielsweise im torhaus
waren schon gegen 10 uhr zu 100 prozent
ausgelastet was dazu geführt hat dass
der verkehr sich durch den gesamten
oberharz gestaut hat über viele viele
kilometer die wettersituation hat doch
dafür gesorgt dass die autos im schnee
stecken geblieben sind mein kollege und
ich sind selber zweimal steckengeblieben
mussten von helfern wieder befreit
werden
es ist sehr sehr kalt
viele leute sind jetzt im abreiseverkehr
und werden mit sicherheit noch ein zwei
stunden hier auch im verkehr fest hängen
da die witterungsbedingungen immer
schlechter werden die räumfahrzeuge sind
hinter mir im dauereinsatz aber sie
kriegen die straßen hier gar nicht frei
dennis vielen herzlichen dank in den
harz und wir schauen jetzt einen großen
feldberg im taunus dort steht mein
kollege kolja gärtner ja auch hier wurde
weiträumig abgesperrt mit dem auto ist
kein durchkommen mehr
hier lassen sich davon denn die
schneebegeisterten irgendwie abhalten
das ist heute deutlich weniger als in
den letzten tagen hier los ist auf dem
parkplatz hinter mir auf dem sonst
hunderte von autos stehen sind jetzt
gerade mal 20 auf der schützenwiese die
sonst überrannt wird von den
frankfurtern und den menschen aus den
anderen städten im rhein-main-gebiet
tummeln sich vielleicht zwei dutzend
leute drei dutzend leute viele davon aus
dem ort es haben aber trotzdem immer
noch ein paar es geschafft
hierdurch zu kommen obwohl im umkreis
von zehn kilometern straßensperren der
polizei sind die sind dann häufig durch
über forst und waldwegen gefahren was
brandgefährlich ist denn es herrscht
viel schneebruchgefahr es heißt es
stürzten bäume um
kann man sich vorstellen was los ist
wenn man so einen ab trägt damit zurück
nach berlin
vielen herzlichen dank an unsere
reporter draußen in den skigebieten mehr
nachrichten und breaking news nur bei
bet schau dir das nächste video an und
vergiss nicht zu abonnieren